on va commencer par licorne le nikon qui
me regardait beaucoup sur france 4
au début sur des mythes et tu m'as
zapper à mais complètement
bah non c'est pas là ça va ma chérie
t'inquiète pas alors dis moi tu comptes
et non parce que voilà les pour et
contre ceux d'accor match et n'ont donc
tu voudrais quoi que je fasse quoi je
suis tout sauf de la télé pour éviter de
voir ta tête d'accor attendait et aux
non non et on a demandé à licorne
devenir s'est elle dit ce qu'elle pense
voilà donc là là tu viens cauchemar non
j'ai pas un cauchemar je suis super
content de pouvoir le dire face à face
et bah ça fait plaisir je suis quelqu'un
j'aime bien être franc exactement j'aime
bien montrer justement ce que j'ai à
dire est ce que tu veux nombreux tweets
sur moi je l'aurais chaque fois beaucoup
alors dis nous ce qui te dérange et à
petit nous pourquoi tu es contre moi à
la nar dix mois zada parce que je trouve
que les choses ont beaucoup changé
depuis le début des émissions
donc comme je disais je regardais tpm
fait depuis le début et au fur et à
mesure du temps ce qui les passe à des
visites c'est pas ça c'est 8 parce que
bon la chambre et changer de nom sur de
plus en plus moi je te tutoie pas ce que
tu est de la même génération que moi
mais têtue vous regardez sur france 4
aussi ouais c'est ça mais même au niveau
de l'ambiance générale des chroniqueurs
ya un malaise quoi mais alors on revient
à un malaise complet mais maintenant tu
dis tu dis ce que tu mens est ce que tu
penses pas c'est plutôt les gens qui ont
changé par rapport à nous parce que
serena ambitions a eu un énorme succès
et c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
gens qui se sont intéressés à l'émission
et qu'on fait peut-être que chaque chose
qui se passait dans l'émission devenait
un énorme buzz alors le buzz moi déjà je
suis un peu contre le faux buzz
oui mais dont l effet que nous mais nous
tu vois ya beaucoup de journalistes
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle les pus
tacle c'est parce qu'ils savent que
voilà ça fait énormément parler pour
faire des articles contre nous c'est
vrai qu'ils font que forcément
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois
qu'on fait quelque chose c'est beaucoup
plus scrutés que lorsqu'on était sur
france 4 on faisait du bois cent
cinquante mille téléspectateurs c'est un
peu normal encore cherche tout ça on
l'obtient non mais non on cherche pas
c'est vrai que moi je trouve quand même
que petit à petit au niveau de ton
comportement haut niveau sa façon d'être
des gros mots sa façon
et nous on prend plus fameux jeu j'ai
des racines serra sera qui le dérange
pas tout où tous les regards marmont
frères lacroix
voilà tout ça mon père mais moi je
comprends rien de quoi
[Applaudissements]
j'adore c'est bien qu'elle le dise
norvège avec délégués qui voulait
prendre la parole oui bonsoir 6 rebonds
soir à tous moi je moi je trouve ça très
dandy je voudrais vous remercier d'être
venu et je loue votre courage parce que
ça change de tous les acteurs ski qui
interviennent en ce moment sur twitter
et qui peuvent balancer des insultes
donc je vous remercie d'être là face à
nous justement ce que vous dites c'est
la différence par rapport à la première
moi je la regarde donc depuis 2010
depuis la première et moi au contraire
je vois un fil conducteur par rapport à
la première édition et je trouve que
cyril est le même
je vais même vous dire mieux l'émission
en fait je pense que c'est ce qui gêne
l'émission est devenue populaire et moi
populaire n'est pas un gros mot
contrainte c'est un mot que
j'affectionne et et c'est ce que disait
cyril vous pour avoir donc pour bosser
dans la communication et pour connaître
des journalistes qui bossent surtout
indigne ils nous le disent quand on est
en ligne
il faut faire des il faut faire du clic
parce que c'est ça qui nous fait ramener
de l'argent et quand on fait un article
sur hanouna comme on fait un article sur
les pmp avec 1 1 avec un titre plus ta
clique ont fait de losail et et c'est ce
que nous faisons c'est dingue et c'est
dingue mais malheureusement cela c'est
ça qu'on voit actuellement
malheureusement scénario si vous
regardez des articles généralement c'est
un micro événement vraiment un micro
événement et qu'ils enfant sache il
avouera permettre un triplé comme moyen
un journaliste qui m'a dit franchement
tous les jours il ya des artistes des
articles sur moi
cyril hanouna au fond du gouffre cyril
hanouna wind et cyril hanouna n'a plus
d'amis j aimerais tu fais ça inhibe non
je te dis la vérité
dès que voilà je fais c'est juste pour
faire du clic parce que voilà des cons
mettons-nous avec un truc que négatif à
côté ça ça ça cartonne
et le mec me l'a dit franchement j'ai du
bac ou tu sais quoi continue alors si tu
peux faire ton business là dessus - la
limite ça me dérange par la semelle en
parle de business on parle depuis
taquine assure de tout ça mais moi c'est
pas ça le le principal de pourquoi je
t'aime pas voici en fait
c'est très pratique pourquoi pas ta
gueule quoi non mais alors ouais alors
oui licornebasée parce que voilà c'est
tous et toutes ces petites choses qui se
sont greffés géant mesure du temps ta
façon d'être
tes rires de yale mais deviennent voilà
mais c'est sûr jouer ses droits réels
c'est pas vrai métier que j'ai toujours
été quelqu'un il faut que ça il ya quand
même une part de vérité
et si c'est trop sûr jouer les gens ils
se détournent pourquoi il ya moins
d'audience aujourd'hui j'ai 90 à odos
toujours toutes les émissions et presque
deux millions on est amis en trois oui
mais oui mes amis ont trois matches et
ris parce que les jeux voices est à 10
millions us soit 3 millions ma chérie
mais ça demande un peu non mais tout mon
rêve et c'est bon bah on avait toujours
souhaité et voilà que ce mardi là moi de
mon dos à télé mais en termes de
pourcentage on fait toujours les mêmes
aux audiences depuis maintenant hausse
et on garde les mêmes audiences depuis
sept ans tu vois donc c'est vrai que
c'est un exploit voilà après toi toi tu
nous a délaissé j'espère que tu
reviendras nous voir si tu veux je pense
personnellement je m'étais bien curieuse
ap
je vois ta tête je peux plus et quand
c'est castaldi tu regarde jamais jamais
on peut le dire pas ses yeux dit chantal
armagnac et balances ton post
mais alors balance n'ont pas de regarder
ou pas testing je vous adore avancé away
sincèrement tu veux que jamais trompé
j'adore j'adore balance au poste gentil
je les regardais depuis le tout premier
numéro du mois franchement je trouve ces
mais c'est bien ma gueule dans l'oeil de
balances ton bonheur justement
mais elle regarde les contrats mais par
les ducs c'est moi elsa parce que pour
moi j'ai regardé à l'époque dechavanne
oisienne ou mardi ça me rappelle
énormément tout à zurich sans que
j'adorais les fight entre les pour les
petits ça c'est très classe a libéré les
les rats j'adore ces exercices que tu
fais sur les plaies ah oui ah oui
j'adore mais le pourrai faudrait un peu
plus quoi ils avaient des chroniqueurs
jo et mika et pour les balances ton post
sincèrement vu que moi je t'aime pas en
tant que personnage nature généreuse qui
regardent l'émission quand même ces
démissions pour les chroniqueurs
d'accord jimmy pour christine alors
justement d'un clavier monde christine
toi tu es pour bon c'est normal de tous
bords oui elle à moi déjà je voudrais
bien inviter licorne sous effectivement
la responsabilité de serre et à le
suivre quand même une petite journée
juste ont coulé le tube tu veux qu'elle
meure ou non c'est non non non c'est
intéressant de voir à quel point il est
exactement le même
avant et après le générique et ça fait
partie des raisons pour lesquelles les
rires du reviennent tous âges mais
jamais rien de vienne c'est juste une
semaine avec moi et ouais la licorne
pourquoi est-ce que je suis là c'est
justement malicorne
c'est d'abord parce que j'aime son
personnage parce qu'il est généreux
alors bien sûr j'aurais pu aller sur
d'autres émissions avant mais j'ai aimé
sa générosité jamais je connais beaucoup
de patrons de chaînes de présentateurs
télé d'animateur de journalistes jamais
je n'ai vu quelqu'un jeudi avant même de
travailler avec lui
jamais je n'ai vu quelqu'un d'aussi
généreux avec son public a même quand
les juniors
[Applaudissements]
t comme s'il n'est pas là est ce que je
dis depuis le chauffeur de salle non non
vous n'êtes pas non mais par exemple
quand la lumière s'éteint et parle au
public on n'est plus là il reste à
parler avec eux quand il ya la publie
par le public quand il ya des personnes
en difficulté il va les aider quand les
caméras sont éteintes il va dans les
hôpitaux voir les enfants c'est ça qui
me plaît chez ce bonhomme que beaucoup
ne comprennent pas